En cuanto a inventos,
quiero contarles la historia de uno de mis proyectos favoritos.
Creo que es uno de los proyectos más emocionantes en los que estoy trabajando,
pero también es el más simple.
Es un proyecto que tiene el potencial para hacer un gran impacto en todo el mundo.
Trata sobre uno de los problemas de salud más grandes del mundo,
la causa número uno de muertes en niños menores de cinco años,
¿Cuál es...? ¿Enfermedades por contaminación de agua? ¿Diarrea? ¿Desnutrición?
No, son las enfermedades agudas causadas por
la respiración de gases de la cocina a fuego en el interior. ¿Pueden creerlo?
Encuentro esto chocante y algo atróz.
¿Podemos hacer combustibles de quemado más limpios?
¿Podemos hacer mejores hornos?
¿Cómo es que esto puede causar cada año dos millones de muertes?
Se que Bill Joy les estuvo hablando
acerca de las maravillas de los nanotubos de carbono.
Así que yo les voy a hablar
de las maravillas de los macrotubos de carbono, que es el carbón.
Entonces, esta es una imagen rural de Haití. Haití está ahora desforestada en un 98 por ciento.
Se pueden ver escenas como éstas por toda la isla.
Esto conduce a todo tipo de problemas ambientales
y problemas que afectan a las personas en toda la nación.
Hace unos años hubo una inundación
que dejó miles de muertes,
esto es atribuible directamente al hecho
de que no hay árboles en las laderas para estabilizar la tierra.
Entonces viene la lluvia, baja por los ríos y sucede la inundación.
Ahora, una de las razones por la que hay pocos árboles es que
la gente necesita cocinar, así que talan los bosques
y hacen carbón para poder hacerlo.
No es que la gente sea ignorante sobre el daño al medio ambiente.
Lo saben perfectamente bien, pero no tienen otra alternativa.
Los combustibles fósiles no están disponibles,
y la energía solar no cocina como a ellos les gusta su comida.
Entonces esa es la forma en que lo hacen.
Encontrarán familias como esta yendo al bosque a buscar un árbol,
lo cortan y hacen carbón con él.
Entonces no es una sorpresa que haya mucho esfuerzo
puesto en buscar combustibles alternativos para cocinar.
Hace unos 4 años llevé un grupo de estudiantes a Haití,
y trabajamos con Voluntarios del Cuerpo de Paz allí.
Este es uno de esos voluntarios,
y este es un dispositivo que hizo en la villa donde trabajaba.
Y la idea era que podías poner papel de desperdicio,
comprimirlo, y hacer bloques que podían usarse como combustible.
Pero este dispositivo era muy lento.
Así que nuestros estudiantes de ingeniería se pusieron a trabajar en el,
y con unos simples cambios,
pudieron triplicar el rendimiento de este dispositivo.
Así que podrán imaginarse que estaban muy emocionados por ello.
Y llevaron los bloques al MIT para poder probarlos.
Y una de las cosas que descubrieron es que no ardían.
Así que fue un poco desalentador para los estudiantes.
De hecho, si miran de cerca, justo aquí,
pueden leer que dice "Cuerpo de Paz Estadounidense".
Resulta que realmente no había desperdicio de papel en esta aldea.
Y mientras era un buen uso del papeleo gubernamental
para este voluntario, llevarlo a la aldea,
estaba a 800 kilometros de distancia.
Entonces pensamos que debería haber una mejor manera
de idear un combustible de cocina alternativo.
Lo que queríamos era hacer un combustible
que usara algo que ya estuviera disponible a nivel local.
También verán esto en todo Haití. Son pequeños molinos de azúcar.
Y el producto de desperdicio de los mismos
después de extraído el jugo de la caña de azúcar se llama bagazo.
No tiene otro uso. No tiene valor nutricional,
así que no lo usan para alimentar animales.
Solo está en una pila cerca del molino de azúcar, hasta que eventualmente lo queman.
Lo que queríamos hacer era encontrar una manera
de aprovechar esta fuente de desperdicio y convertirla en combustible
que sería algo con lo que la gente podría cocinar fácilmente,
algo como el carbón.
Así que durante el siguiente par de años, los estudiantes y yo trabajamos para desarrollar un proceso.
Asi que empiezan con el bagazo, después toman un simple hornillo
que pueden hacer de un tanque de 210 litros de combustible.
Después de un tiempo, después de prenderle fuego, lo sellan
para restringir el oxígeno que entra en el hornillo,
y después les queda este material carbonizado aquí.
Sin embargo, no pueden encender esto. Es muy fino
y se quema demasiado rápido como para usarse para cocinar.
Así que tuvimos que probar y encontrar alguna manera de hacerlos bloques útiles.
Y convenientemente, uno de mis estudiantes era de Ghana,
y recordó un plato que su madre solía hacerle, llamado "kokonte".
que es un empaste pegajoso hecho a base de raíces de casava.
Así que lo que hicimos fue mirar, y encontramos
que la casava efectivamente crecía en Haití, bajo el nombre de mandioca.
Y de hecho, crece en todo el mundo --
yuca, tapioca, mandioca, casava, son todas la misma cosa --
una raíz vegetal muy almidonada.
Y pueden hacer con el un bloque muy grueso y sólido,
que puede usarse para unir los bloques de carbón.
Así que hicimos esto. Fuimos a Haití.
Estos son los graduados de la primer "Escuela del Carbón",
o Instituto del Carbón. Y estos --
(Risas)
-- es correcto. Soy una instructora del MIT así como del CIT.
Y estos son los bloques que hicimos.
Ahora, los voy a llevar a otro continente. Esto es India,
y este es el combustible de cocina más usado en la India: el estiércol de vaca.
Y más que en Haití, esto produce fuegos realmente humeantes,
y aquí es donde realmente se ven los impactos en la salud
de cocinar con estiércol de vaca y biomasa como combustible.
Los niños y mujeres son los más afectados,
porque son los que están cerca de los fuegos de cocina.
Así que quisimos ver si podíamos introducir
esta tecnología para hacer carbón allí.
Desafortunadamente, no tenían caña de azúcar
y no tenían casava, pero eso no nos detuvo.
Lo que hicimos fue, descubrimos cuales eran las fuentes de biomasa disponibles localmente.
Y encontramos paja de trigo y de arroz en esa área.
Y lo que podíamos usar como comparación
eran pocas cantidades de estiércol de vaca,
que usaban comúnmente para su combustible.
E hicimos pruebas lado a lado, y aquí pueden ver
los bloques de carbón, y aquí el estiércol de vaca.
Y pueden ver que es una combustión mucho más limpia del combustible para cocinar.
Y de hecho, calienta el agua mucho más rápido.
Y entonces eramos muy felices, hasta ahí.
Pero una de las cosas que encontramos
fue que cuando hicimos comparaciones lado a lado con carbón de madera,
no ardían tanto tiempo. Y los bloques se desmoronaban un poco,
y perdíamos energía cuando se deshacían mientras cocinábamos.
Entonces, queríamos encontrar la forma de hacer un bloque más fuerte
para poder competir con el carbón vegetal en los mercados de Haití.
Así que volvimos al MIT, sacamos la máquina Instron (máquina de pruebas de fuerza),
y averiguamos qué tipos de fuerzas necesitábamos
para comprimir el bloque a un nivel
que pudiéramos obtener un mejor rendimiento.
Y al mismo tiempo que teníamos estudiantes en el laboratorio observando esto,
también teníamos unos colegas en Haití trabajando para desarrollar el proceso,
para mejorarlo y hacerlo más accesible a los aldeanos de allí.
Y después de un tiempo,
desarrollamos una prensa de bajo costo que permite producir carbón,
que, de hecho, arde por más tiempo y de forma más limpia que el carbón de madera.
Entonces ahora estamos en una situación en la que tenemos el producto, que es incluso mejor
que lo que se puede comprar en los mercados de Haití,
que es un maravilloso lugar para estar.
Solo en Haití, alrededor de 30 millones de árboles se talan cada año.
Hay una posibilidad de que esto sea implementado
y así salvar una buena porción de aquellos árboles.
Además, los ingresos generados por ese carbón son de 260 millones de dólares.
Eso es una enorme cantidad para el país de Haití --
con una población de ocho millones
y un ingreso promedio menor a 400 dólares.
Así que es también hacia allí que nos movemos con el proyecto del carbón.
Y una de las cosas que creo que es también interesante,
es que tengo un amigo en la Universidad de California, Berkeley, que está haciendo un análisis del riesgo.
Y él ha considerado los problemas del impacto en la salud
de prender leña versus prender carbón.
Y él ha decubierto que a nivel mundial,
uno puede prevenir millones de muertes con solo cambiar de madera a carbón
como combustible para la cocina. Eso es notable.
Pero hasta el momento, no había manera de hacerlo sin talar árboles.
Pero ahora tenemos un método
que utiliza material de desecho de agricultura para crear combustible de cocina.
Una de las cosas realmente emocionante es, sin embargo
algo que surgió de un viaje que hice a Ghana el mes pasado.
Y esto es, creo, lo más cool,
y es incluso menos tecnológico que lo que acaban de ver,
si pudieran imaginar tal cosa. Aquí está.
Entonces, ¿qué es esto? Estas son mazorcas de maíz convertidas a carbón.
Y la belleza de esto, radica en que no se necesita hacer bloques.
Ya viene hecho. Esta es mi notebook de 100 dólares, justo aquí.
Y, como Nick, traje muestras.
(Risas)
Entonces podemos ir pasando estas.
Son totalmente funcionales, ya fueron probadas y están listas para el mercado.
Y pienso que otra cosa que es realmente notable de esta tecnología
es que la transferencia de la tecnología es tan fácil.
Comparada con el carbón de caña de azúcar,
donde en realidad tenemos que enseñarle a la gente cómo formarlo en bloques
y tienen el paso extra de cocinar el tambor,
esto viene pre-fabricado.
Y esto es casi lo más emocionante en mi vida en este momento,
lo que probablemente sea un comentario muy triste acerca de mi vida.
(Risas)
Pero una vez que lo vean, como ustedes, la gente en la primera fila, de acuerdo,
si, OK. Entonces, de todas maneras --
(Risas)
--- aquí está. Y esto, creo, es un ejemplo perfecto
de lo que hablaba Robert White en esas cosas de suma no-cero.
Así que no solo tienen beneficios para la salud,
sino que también tienen beneficios para el medio ambiente.
Pero esta es una de esas situaciones increíblemente raras
donde también tienen beneficios económicos.
Las personas pueden hacer su propio combustible de cocina con productos de deshecho.
Pueden generar ingresos con esto.
Pueden ahorrar el dinero que iban a gastar en carbón,
y pueden producir exceso y venderlo en el mercado
a las personas que no están fabricando el suyo.
Es realmente raro que no tengan un intercambio
entre salud y economía, o medio ambiente y economía.
Así que este es un proyecto que encuentro extremadamente emocionante,
y estoy ansiosa por ver hasta donde nos puede llevar.
O sea, cuando hablamos ahora, del futuro que vamos a crear
una de las cosas que yo creo es necesaria
es tener una visión muy clara del mundo en que vivimos.
Y ahora en realidad no me refiero al mundo en el que nosotros vivimos.
Me refiero al mundo donde las mujeres pasan de dos a tres horas cada día
moliendo granos para que su familia pueda comer.
Me refiero al mundo donde los materiales de construcción avanzados
son las tejas de cemento hechas a mano,
y donde, cuando trabajan diez horas al día,
siguen ganando solo 60 dólares al mes.
Me refiero al mundo donde niños y mujeres pasan 40 billones de horas cada año yendo a buscar agua.
Eso es como si la fuerza de trabajo completa del estado de California
trabajara jornada completa durante un año, no haciendo otra cosa que ir a buscar agua.
Es un lugar, donde, por ejemplo, si esto fuera la India,
en esta habitación, solo tres de nosotros tendrían un auto.
Si esto fuese Afganistán,
solo una persona en esta habitación sabría usar Internet.
Si esto fuese Zambia, 300 de ustedes serían granjeros,
100 de ustedes tendrían SIDA o VIH.
Y más de la mitad de ustedes estarían viviendo con menos de un dólar por día.
Estas son las cuestiones para las que tenemos que hallar soluciones.
Estas son las cuestiones para las que necesitamos entrenar a nuestros ingenieros,
nuestros diseñadores, nuestra gente de negocios, nuestros empresarios, para que las enfrenten.
Estas son las soluciones que necesitamos hallar.
Tengo algunas áreas donde creo que es especialmente importante que nos enfoquemos.
Una de ellas es crear tecnologías para promover micro-financiamientos y micro-empresas,
para que la gente que vive debajo de la línea de pobreza, encuentre una salida --
que no lo están pudiendo hacer
usando el mismo sistema tradicional de realizar canastas, criar aves, etcétera.
Pero hay nuevas tecnologías y nuevos productos
que ellos pueden realizar a baja escala.
Lo otro que creo es que necesitamos crear teconogías para granjeros pobres
para agregarle valor a sus propias cosechas.
Y necesitamos repensar nuestras estrategias de desarrollo,
para que no estemos promocionando campañas educativas
para que dejen de ser granjeros,
sino que en cambio dejen de ser granjeros pobres.
Y necesitamos pensar cómo podemos hacer eso eficientemente.
Tenemos que trabajar con las personas en estas comunidades,
y darles los recursos y herramientas que necesitan
para resolver sus propios problemas. Esa es la mejor manera de hacerlo.
No deberíamos hacerlo desde afuera.
Entonces, necesitamos crear este futuro, y tenemos que empezar ahora.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Decinos -- mientras vemos si alguien tiene una pregunta --
contanos sobre otra de las cosas en las que has trabajado.
Amy Smith: Un par de cosas en las que estamos trabajando
son, buscar formas económicas de hacer pruebas de calidad al agua,
para que las comunidades puedan mantener sus propios sistemas de agua,
saber cuando están trabajando, saber cuando tratarla, etc.
También estamos viendo sistemas de tratamiento de agua de bajo costo.
Una de las cosas realmente emocionante es la desinfección solar del agua,
y mejorar la habilidad para hacerlo.
CA: ¿Cuál es el cuello de botella para prevenir que esto se vaya de escala?
¿Necesitan encontrar empresarios o inversionistas de capitales de riesgo,
o qué necesitan para tomar lo que tienen y escalarlo?
AS: Si, yo creo que muchas personas moviéndolo hacía adelante.
Es algo dificil: es un mercado muy fragmentado
y la población que consume sin ingresos.
Así que no pueden usarse los mismos modelos que en Estados Unidos
para que esto avance.
Y somos un grupo pequeño, o sea yo.
(Risas)
Así que, ya saben, hacemos lo que podemos con mis estudiantes.
Tenemos 30 estudiantes por año yendo al campo
y tratando de implementarlo y hacerlo avanzar.
Lo otro, es que esto hay que hacerlo con una escala de tiempo amplia,
como -- ya saben, no pueden esperar obtener algo en uno o dos años.
Tienen que mirar cinco o diez años para adelante.
Pero creo que con la visión de hacerlo, podemos avanzar.